you thought dorsey was bad wait until
you hear
gavin newsom's apology so you remember
gavin newsom we covered this on the show
maybe yesterday gavin newsom
broke his own mandates he broke his own
lockdown rules
he told everyone you can't go out you
can't go to restaurants wear the mask
all the time
he shows up to his buddy's birthday
party at french laundry which is an
extraordinarily expensive michelin rated
restaurant
something like 350 or 400 a plate
i looked if you want to add the ricotta
gnocchi the little a little dish of
ricotta gnocchi it's like a 150
up charge okay it is uh
it's a nice restaurant and gavin newsom
didn't want to miss out on this party so
he goes and he thought the cameras were
off and he got caught
just like so many leftists have nancy
pelosi goes and gets her hair cut
all these other guys chris cuomo goes on
a run in the hamptons when he pretends
that he's
holding up in his basement and he's
going on a run he's going on a bike ride
he gets into a fight with a guy
they're all just lying to you all of
these people and then he gets caught
and he makes an apology that i was
listening very carefully
and for the first almost minute of it i
couldn't discern
any actual apology a few weeks ago
i was asked to go to a friend's 50th
birthday
my wife and i friend that i've known for
almost 20
years and and a friend that had invite
well
put a lot of time and energy into his
50th birthday
it was in napa which was in the orange
status relatively
loose compared to some other counties it
was
to be an outdoor uh restaurant and we
started the well the program started
four o'clock it was one of those early
reservations i got there a little bit
late at 4 30
and as soon as i sat down at the larger
table i realized it was a little larger
group
than i had anticipated and i made a bad
mistake
okay hold on there it is what was the
time what time did you have
i had 44 seconds of excuses
before he even started to intimate
that he had done anything wrong which by
the way he didn't ultimately say
he said i made a mistake but he didn't
make a mistake he chose to violate his
own orders
he chose to be a giant hypocrite he
chose to go to his buddies birthday
party at the really nice restaurant so
it's not a mistake it's not an accident
like whoopsie daisy
oh no the french laundry fell down in
front of me i guess i'll eat the ricotta
gnocchi
whoops oh no oh my mouth is open and the
delicious regular and yucky you're
falling in no you chose to go
and you then give 44 look my friend
we've been friends for a long time so
that you know that makes it okay
and look he put a lot of time and effort
into his birthday not like your idiot
friends i mean you those you're lazy
stupid friends they would and by the way
your friends couldn't even afford the
french laundry so you don't really
it's just different you don't really get
it so i got there got there a little bit
late you know i'm pretty busy on the
governor and everything
and i saw look there are a few more
people but it's like come on it's my
buddy's birthday and i want to do it and
i'm i'm the ruler of california and i
don't have to play by the same rules
that i make everybody else follow
you know i made a mistake so then
he explains his mistake instead of
sitting down i should have
stood up and walked back got in my car
and drove back
uh to my house instead i chose to sit
there with my wife
and a number of other couples that were
outside the household and you can
quibble about
the guidelines et cetera et cetera but
the spirit of
what i'm preaching all the time uh was
contradicted and i got to own that and
so i want to apologize to you
hold up stop it no you're not
apologizing at all
because even when you say i made a
mistake which is not true it wasn't a
mistake it was very intentional
you say look and we get there i was
sitting there with some people and look
really i mean you could quibble about
the guidelines because like
see actually i didn't i didn't really
violate them i think i mean but look we
can let's we can quibble
okay you you can have your view i can
have my view will agree to disagree
no you can't quibble buddy you broke the
rules you had the rules
that said you couldn't go to that
restaurant with all those many people
all together from different households
you you made those rules and then you
broke them so i'm not going to quibble
about anything
you just want to hold your constituents
to a completely different standard
than you will hold yourself to because
you wanted those delicious gnocchi
at french laundry no quibbling
whatsoever
she says yeah i shouldn't look okay and
so i apologize good apologize please
give me the apology are we gonna get an
apology
i need to preach and practice not just
preach and not practice and i've done my
best to do that
we're all human we all fall short
sometimes
uh we've been out i think for three
times since in fact i know
it's been three times because i remember
all of those dinners very very vividly
since february just three times twice
with my wife by myself
outdoors and then this one occasion with
a larger group and there were just a few
extra people there uh then the spirit of
what
i am promoting oh it's not even an
apology
you're just trying to get ahead of the
story that's inevitably going to come
out that you've broken your own
guidelines other times as well
that's what this has been goes yeah and
look okay i did it i made a mistake i
have to and i've probably i've done a
couple other times too
um what was that governor newsome no
yeah no it's really i know i'm going to
keep smiling and it's all
look it's kind of a big misunderstanding
but yeah for a while now i've been
disregarding the rules that i'm making
you all follow and i know that
maybe there's a chance some journalist
is going to cover this so
because the sacramento bee's really
angry at me so yeah i've done it a few
times but
look hey you know everyone makes
mistakes okay can we move on can we move
past this please
hahaha and i think i still am waiting
for the
the real apology to come in and he just
closes his message to the people
smiling and so if we're gonna minimize
mixing you gotta
you gotta own up to that so i just want
folks to know that
paid for our dinner uh and we uh you
know
we had an early dinner but didn't matter
i shouldn't have been there
i should have turned back around and uh
so when that happens
you gotta you pay the price but you also
own the mistake and you don't ever make
it again
and you have my word on that and you
have my word okay you gotta pay the
price i
obviously i don't i'm not gonna pay any
price and i'm not even really admitting
i did anything wrong it was an early
dinner you know it wasn't a late dinner
and i paid my way by the way
hey if any of you ethics researchers are
looking into this i paid for my dinner
even though they're
they're definitely lobbyists there but
anyway it's
all a big misunderstanding you gotta
take ownership which i will never ever
do
i'm governor newsom goodbye does he look
sorry does he sound sorry to you
no not at all did chris cuomo sound
sorry no he didn't sound sorry at all
when he lied about quarantining with
coronavirus and he didn't actually
quarantine
he went outside and then he lied about
it then he filmed this whole ridiculous
charade
of him coming out of his basement for
the first time he wasn't coming out for
the first time
in weeks and seeing his family he had
been out
and about on long island so much so that
he got into a fight with a guy in the
street
nancy pelosi did nancy pelosi apologize
when she got caught going to that
hairdresser without a mask
in violation of the lockdown orders no
she actually blamed the hairdresser do
you remember that i said oh this was a
set up i shouldn't have go i can't
believe she did that to me
no lady you broke your own rules what do
you mean her fault own up to your
mistake
dr fauci same thing even dr fatchi a
little less so it was a little less
publicized
how many times did that guy get caught
without a mascot after he told all of us
that we have to have our masks on
after he told all of us that none of us
can have our masks on none of these guys
pay a price for any of it why
because conservatives are not
ruling the country even when it's trump
even when
the republicans have both houses of
congress and the presidency
conservatives are not ruling this
country ever
the left rules this country you know
just just the social media example alone
i don't even want to talk too much about
this
social media issue because i feel
nothing comes of these
of these hearings but during this
hearing
the left democrats maisie hirono in
particular democratic senator from
hawaii
had the audacity to say social media
they're not
they're not biased against conservatives
actually
actually in many ways they're biased in
favor of conservatives
mr zuckerberg for the second time in
three weeks you've been
called before the senate committee so my
republican colleagues can
beat you up over claims that your
platforms are supposedly biased against
conservatives
the fact of the matter is that these
allegations are completely baseless
everyone who has systematically looked
at the content on social
media from media matters to the cato
institute to former republican senator
john
kyle has found absolutely no evidence of
anti-conservative bias
no evidence whatsoever of
anti-conservative bias and what's my
source
oh um media matters
far left radical activist organization
that
is watching my show right now
that there's a guy he's i i actually i
have great affection for this guy
he watch is like the number one fan of
the show he watches
my show every single day my friend jason
campbell
and then whenever he can get like a good
clip and try to sort of
make it seem like i said something wrong
he will break it out they'll do and
they'll try to get conservatives fired
that's what the organization exists to
do it is a radical left organization
and maisie hirono is citing this
organization
as though they're unbiased fact checkers
that's what they all do
you know some are a little subtler about
it than than media matters
you know media matters to their credit
at least they generally acknowledge that
they're very far left-wing
but but other fact-checking websites
that always
almost all the time seem to cut against
conservatives and
twist what conservatives are saying and
defend what liberals are saying
and bend over backwards to try to
rewrite what the liberals are saying to
defend it
politifact i'm thinking of snopes even
other organizations that fact check for
for
big tech those groups
will suppress a story those groups
according
reported later the biden campaign can
throw a presidential election
that's real power that's real power
and the truth doesn't really matter and
then they have the gall
to come to you and say that
conservatives don't care about the truth
barack obama was just talking about this
barack obama says that
there is a truth decay in this country
that that republicans and conservatives
and trump in particular
are overthrowing all these wonderful
norms
in our republic we have gone through a
presidency
that disregarded a whole host of
basic institutional norms
expectations we have for a president
that have been observed by republicans
and democrats uh previously
and maybe most importantly uh and
most disconcertingly what we've seen is
what some people call truth decay
something that's been accelerated by
outgoing president trump the sense that
not only do we not have to tell the
truth
but the truth doesn't even matter pause
right there obviously the the hypocrisy
is is manifest uh talking about
overturning norms and things like that
talk about truth doesn't matter barack
obama actually one time when politifact
did
attack the left politifact pointed out
that the lie of the year was barack
obama who said if you like your doctor
you can keep your doctor and then
when he got caught in that lie he said
what you didn't think you were gonna get
all that insurance for free did you
totally cynical view is that the truth
didn't matter just like he says
when he said that if i pushed executive
amnesty
that would be unconstitutional and then
what's he do he pushes executive amnesty
shrugs his shoulders yep
truth doesn't really matter totally
cynical so obviously there's hypocrisy
there
and if we think of the norms being
constitutional government barack obama
broke a lot of those norms didn't he
he was he was legislating with a pen and
a phone as they say
he was flagrantly violating the law
he was subverting the executive agencies
for his political purposes attacking his
political enemies through the irs and
the doj okay
spying on the trump campaign however i
actually
want to defend what barack obama is
saying here i think he actually is
making a good point
it's a scary point but it's a good point
donald trump has overturned norms not
the constitutional norms those were
overturned
long ago donald trump is overturning the
norms of the liberal order the
progressive administrative state
which grows exponentially
which makes the laws without any
accountability to the people
which continues to move leftward without
any real resistance whatsoever
yeah but politicians in both parties
allowed this to happen democrats and
republicans
bushes and clintons and obama's allowed
this to happen
sure you can tinker around the edges of
policy but you better keep expanding
globalized trade
and you better keep outsourcing jobs and
you better keep the borders open
and you better keep flooding the country
with mass migration and you better keep
lowering wages
and you better keep moving to the left
and you better not put up any real
resistance against the
flood of social radicalism that has
redefined the fundamental political
institutions in the country
better not do any of that and if you are
going to even intimate that you'll do
that you better roll over and lose like
a good republican like mitt romney
you better not answer the media like
george w bush
yeah that's true there were there was
this norm there was this consensus
and it was a rotten norm and it was a
rotten consensus and it was terrible for
the country
and trump whatever flaws you think he
has
cracked that a little bit it's very good
to break up those norms
if you've got constitutional norms and
then progressive norms and those are at
odds
it's good to break up the progressive
norms
that's some truth but for barack obama
he talks about the truth decay
barack obama is one of the most cynical
presidents in american history one of
the least concerned about the truth in
american history
but for him when he's even talking about
the truth what is he talking about
he's talking about a progressive view of
history where we're hurtling toward
utopia where you're on the right side of
history that's his view of the truth not
objective truth
the way that you and i would talk about
it but ideological truth
truth within the system political
correctness political correctness which
is
it sounds similar to truth but it's not
it's actually opposed
to truth absolutely we need to break
that
according to those liberal norms
conservatives lose everything in culture
and politics if you enjoyed that video
and i
would hope that you did please be sure
to hit the subscribe button
so that all of the befuddled radicals
wading through the wasteland
of youtube knows where they can get the
truth
thanks